I'm so grounded today on the shoot floor
hi guys and welcome to for a diary fry
Diaries look back at my week and I
haven't done it for the last two weeks
because I was working on a project that
I was allowed to tell you about that I
was filming some stuff for and now it's
out in the oven if you guys haven't
heard Hannah Hart and I are shooting a
series up here in Vancouver called
Electra woman and Dyna girl which was a
seventies television show and now we are
rebooting it for the digital space and
we are becoming superheroes and we just
started actually filming three days ago
but we have been in Vancouver for over
two weeks doing pre-production and
rehearsals and all that kinds of fun
with the superheroes don't need to speak
right it's all about action not dialogue
right like a Michael Bay movie I don't
know is that a reference people say it
so I just repeat it I think people think
parrots are so smart they just repeat
everything they hear so make sure your
intellectual Mandana girl calm so you
can sign up for information about the
project and updates that get emailed to
you as we go along with this shooting
process without further ado here is a
look back at the last couple weeks of
getting started on the project made it
to the airport with my best friend
Bloody Mary hey Nana Nana has told me
that she has the greatest story to tell
me about her trip to the airport but she
actually wanted to tell me on Friday
areso photo second so I can put the
camera on her account I can't even I
don't even know how to start talking
about this so when I was driving over
my driver told me that the last person
that was in his car
[Music]
and me I've lost all my friends
hybrid re it is the end of Wednesday and
hen and I just got back from an acting
coach session because we start shooting
in a week and a half we're not the
strongest actors in the world but we're
getting there so we are working on some
great stuff the [ __ ] oh I hope you guys
in fact I know now that I definitely
didn't tell you guys this so my foot is
in an ace bandage look how great I am at
rapping yeah so great at rapping ace
bandages so my foot is in the nice band
is because a few days before we came up
here to shoot I went over to Hannah's
place and instead of having her open her
garage backdoor I climbed up over it and
jumped down and I was a little
intoxicated and the next morning I woke
up and the top of my foot hurts so bad
so who knows what happened I think I
like sprained it or something and which
will be really fun because tomorrow we
start our stunt rehearsal oh I'm sorry
I'm just having dinner with a glamour
eye no big deal
and look what's happening boy stuff the
glamour high is touched
[Music]
like those Lighting's perfect it is
Tuesday which is the first day of our
week and Hannah's here and we're going
to do more stunt rehearsal how your
shoulders so there's our shoulder rolls
yeah yeah great content on your feet as
to not give away your costume at this
point in time we're doing hair and
makeup testing it's very exciting
business oh great they're trying to
incorporate the glamorize well a person
loves it and that person's Hannah Hart
[Music]
we're back in the office tonight look
what's here did you see this it's your
little dude except with a mask on like
it is officially day one on set and I'm
in my trailer this thing was just here
waiting for me that's my welcome present
Eva whoa we're actually on lunch
Hannah's been shooting some scenes so
far how they gone really really well if
you guys can tell my hands are actually
like a little bit bruised and stuff
because the scenes I'm shooting I'm like
oh yeah they're just saying I make I'm
flexing too hard it's hurt oh yeah it's
so hard that I got a bruise I think we
have to flex our humility because
they're really trying to give us egos
look at this thing notice here this one
that's our food and then they gave us
this what is that what is that it's so
it's so beautiful when I walked in this
morning I thought to myself oh wow we're
not sharing a trailer and then I was
like oh wow oh wow oh wow oh wow oh wow
oh wow oh wow oh wow oh wow oh wow
really important business is happening
character development story watch this
the tray is becoming with makeup artist
[Music]
it looks great let's wrap them j-1
betrayus here yep attract crazy Hannah
and let go he showed up
god damn michael go fine sneaks on gets
a roll nailing it good morning it's day
to connect strange you guys said we're
shooting in an abandoned mental facility
look at this
pretty terrifying there's ghosts
everywhere apparently can't wait let's
do it there's Hannah she looks great
look I'm not scary all of us is that
looks normal and safe that looks normal
and safe Rhett it's terrifying there you
go there's a look back at the last few
weeks of working on Electra woman and
Dyna girl get ready because we have two
more weeks of shooting and you are
coming with me whether you want to or
not this is take your subscribers to
work day I remember take your daughter
to work day it was like a really fun
thing because you got out of school and
then when I actually went to my mom's
work I was like oh my mom works out of
school I did not think this through I
don't know
literally the last person that was in
his car was Beyonce and jay-z on their
way to the Grammys yeah but I was like
we're here's a get drove them and I was
like oh now see in this car it's like
yep and I was like oh yes I decided to
Beyonce's soda on views like that one I
was like oh I think you believe that and
we're getting closer first President
Barack Obama then being in the same car
I mean that's why really
I don't know I'm a good babysitter it's
not amazing it's really come on this
amazing happen to you oh my god